i swore to my wife and kids that i would
never go up that high again the last
time jake got up that high he died
life's about conquering your fears and
when you have a youtube channel it's
about doing that on camera
today is the perfect day to change that
light bulb honestly didn't even realize
it's still out do you do you remember
how long that thing's been out it's been
out since the first video of the year
quarter digital is facing the hardest
challenge we've ever faced in 2018
replacing that light bulb
before that
whoa wait oh my gosh this light bulb has
been out longer than your son has been
alive that's amazing we tried in
september june we tried to get the key
we tried we tried in august but because
there's only one ladder in the whole
building that's tall enough to get up
there and steve's here today and he has
the key who's gonna be the one climbing
the ladder to get that whoever goes up
on that ladder might die i have things
to do today my hands are frail and weak
you guys are literally doing it on the
day i'm filming did you do a chick i
think you could do it
clint you're athletic
dude i i i can't we might not even have
a light bulb that fits friend no one
else has the key to the ladder because
it belongs to the building not to any of
the people that rent
so
that looks like a big light bulb man i
need to make sure this one's soft white
though
[Music]
ready to climb up it screw some bulbs on
can you do it
no man i gotta film this video man the
video of us changing it you can't do it
can't i just film you no why can't i
just film you
i don't know why you can't do this
i'm filming dude i don't know why i
always got to be the repair guy around
here but no one else can do this
everyone's super busy
there's two ways we could either set it
against the skylight or we could set it
against the wall
why don't you do it do i get hazard pay
no
no
[Music]
all right
just let me just check something like i
feel like you're
trying not to do this light bulb thing
i swore to my wife and kids that i would
never go up that high again
i fell off of a radio tower on a cruise
it was sam's bachelor party nico as the
best man thought it would be a great
idea if we all took a cruise a three-day
trip to ensenada and back sounds like a
lot of fun right well it was until the
last night we were playing trouble in
terrorist town nerf on top deck of the
cruise ship and we were on the carnival
imagination i climbed up on the on the
radio tower because i wanted the
advantage of height by the way
never in no way is this a consent or a
condoning of this in any way shape or
form anyone who does this is a [ __ ]
idiot now i'll explain there's a radio
tower there's a deck about 20 feet up
that has the radio beacon that goes
around and it doesn't stop there's a
little ladder for a technician to get up
there parkoured my way up to this ladder
and then like jumped and grabbed onto
the bottom rung pulled myself up and
climbed up to the top of this where
there was a deck and there's in the
things like 12 feet across and i thought
that it would be no big deal if i
climbed into that deck and as long as i
stayed low and didn't stand up the thing
wouldn't hit me down below dee and clint
start yelling at me what are you doing
get down from there that's so dangerous
i look down at them and i go what do you
mean it's totally fine and as i'm saying
fine this giant thing hits me in the
back flips me over the rail i grab onto
the rails full flip my first thought is
just hold on to the rail you'll just be
able to hold onto the rail and you won't
fall but i had so much force coming back
around and i just hit it and i just
popped off that sent me into a
somersaulting free fall fortunately dee
was standing right there and he put his
arm out like this i happened to rotate
my chest landed on his hand and then
that sort of broke some of the impact
from there i fell flat against the track
um
so
that's what happened and that's that
that that's what happened um it was not
good it was not smart i'm lucky to be
alive passed out and all the guys
thought i was dead but i woke up on my
back and they were all standing around
me
and then they're like can you feel your
toes can you feel your body don't move
they went and they got paramedics they
brought me to the infirmary the worst
thing that happened was
i really really messed up my thumb
my back was like i kind of messed up for
a little while i got stitches on my chin
um and i can't believe that that's the
worst that happened because honestly on
the on the way down i was like
i'm dead i'm gonna die like i'm
it's funny how fast your mind works in
that situation
so that's why i can't go up on the
ladder
today is a glorious day for the last
three months clint and ren have been
sneaking off to go get lunch on their
onewheels the rest of us bipedal humans
without access to glorious wheel device
have just been left here twiddling our
thumb but today i'm wheeling with you
guys
that's right makes me happy do your
worst time cruises you can only do
full-time cruise or none at all yeah so
you're not tom cruise
oh hold on hold on
take that back i'm sorry i take it back
okay okay
[Music]
really loud
[Music]
i think they're great now i can have my
friends ride with me who don't ride one
wheels here in minnesota we did a
scooter and one wheeled gang ride where
we all went out as a big group we rented
scooters or earned leaps in minnesota
and it was just me and ren and ivy had
our one wheels and everybody else on
scooters it was a blast now you can do
it all the time yeah i think it's
awesome scooter gang scooter games
[Music]
i'm such a huge proponent of non i guess
four wheeled transportation in cities
honestly having these electric vehicles
in the studios is awesome when you live
in downtown or work out of downtown it
takes forever to get anywhere not
because there's traffic but because
parking sucks
[Music]
scooters are so so fun check them out
for yourself there's a link in the
description and don't forget we've got a
coupon code if you want to snag one for
yourself get your car save the planet
seriously have some fun live a little
ride a scooter your favorite memory of
2018 so far
this scooter gang
nick
best of luck
godspeed wendy i'm sorry
remove the light bulb you'll come down
safely phase two bring the light bulb up
everything's gonna go great phase three
come down okay all right jared i'm going
up i got you
from grip
i feel like survivor man
[Music]
you got me jared
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
terrific
[Laughter]
you know it's funny that we use the word
terra firma when we get back onto solid
ground
because
the surface of the earth is this thing
that we take for granted as being safe
and being home
and it's not until you leave that
surface when you're aware of the
inherent danger that exists all around
you which is why sailors used to use it
i mean they still do and why probably
astronauts and other people that leave
the surface of the earth to come back to
it
have this concept of terra firma and
it's not something we talk about in
regular life
because it's just taken for granted
but the truth of it is that
it's very delicate
[Music]
all right now i am
putting the bulb
[Music]
into the socket
oh yeah that's right it will turn on
won't it
this is like
[Music]
we did it boys
yeah it's just it's just got to heat up
all right now
i feel like an astronaut up here boys
really deep down who are you well that's
the thing to find out that's the thing
that's been forgotten see that's the
underside of the tapestry the thing
that's been left out
every one of us
deep deep inside
is a
an act of a function of a performance of
a manifestation of
the whole blinking cosmos
with all its galaxies and forever and
ever and ever whatever it is beyond that
god
in the western tradition or brahman
in hindu philosophy or tao in chinese
every one of us is really that but we
are
pretending we aren't
and i remember being up on the
scaffolding
job
and i was like dad
how do you guys work like this every day
and he goes
you just get used to it
actually that monologue helped a lot i
just wasn't thinking about it
well i really hope everyone in the
studio appreciates what we've
accomplished here today it's been a long
time coming
and gideon that one's for you big boy
i mean i have no idea what you're
rolling on but dropped out of college
okay
i have a flight at three oh dude okay so
you had a week you worked through that
whole week that week is now done yeah
the video done
i'm done
i did it i finished i started writing
this almost exactly a year ago
you